the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons
by the end we had two and nearly as few
targaryens
the rel do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video
well my friends we now have another
official update from hbo
i think this is great news because it
helps back up what i said in my last
video
i don't know how many of you were able
to see my last video but i showed some
information from a website that stated
house of the dragon will begin filming
on april 5th
in that video i said if filming does
actually begin in only 8 weeks then hbo
will need to hire some more actors soon
because up until then
they had only hired about 5 actors for
the series so far
and as we all know house of the dragon
will have a hell of a lot more
characters than that
well it looks like that's exactly what
they've done
the official social media accounts for
game of thrones just released a
statement about what other actors will
be in the show
now if you're familiar with the dance of
dragons then you can already make an
educated guess at what characters we
will need to see
if you're not familiar with the dance of
dragons then i would highly recommend
watching my video
where i explain most of the major events
surrounding this era in westerosi
history
i will link that video down below if you
watch that video you will have a good
idea about what we will most likely see
happen in the new series house of the
dragon
now if you're new around here and you
feel lost let me catch you up to speed
let's go over to hbo's official website
so you can find out what was just
recently announced a few hours ago
the very first thing you see on their
website is house targaryen sigil
and it says house of the dragon is
coming very soon
this series will be based on george rr
martin's book fire and blood
which covers some of the history of
house targaryen
now it says this series will be set 300
years before the events of game of
thrones but i don't think that's
accurate based on all the characters who
we know will be in the show
the very first actor they hired on for
the series was patty considine who will
be king viserys one targaryen
his reign happened roughly 170 years
before the events of game of thrones not
300 like aegon the conqueror
they really should fix that on their
website unless they're holding back
information we don't know now according
to their character descriptions
viserys was chosen by the lords of
westeros to succeed the old king jiharis
targaryen
at the great council at harrenhal he was
a warm
kind and decent man viserys only wishes
to carry forward his grandfather's
legacy
but as we've learned from game of
thrones good men do not necessarily
make for great kings now before viserys
dies
he names his daughter rhaenyra targaryen
his heir to the iron throne
the reason why he did this was because
he was not able to have any sons of his
own for many years
but king viserys does eventually remarry
a woman named alison hightower
who will also be in the series king
viserys and alicent have
several children together including a
son named aegon targaryen
now you would think since he finally had
a son he would name him his heir
but he doesn't his daughter rhaenyra
targaryen remains as his heir
well that is until he dies as soon as
king viserys dies
his wife alicent as well as some other
notable characters
make sure aegon gets the throne before
rhaenara and this
is what leads to the targaryen civil war
known as the dance of dragons
the actress olivia cook will be viserys
targaryen's wife alison hightower
actress emma diarcy will be his daughter
rhaenyra targaryen who he originally
named as his heir
and matt smith will be one of my
favorite characters in the series daemon
targaryen
brother of king viserys daemon is known
as arguably one of the greatest warriors
from this era so it should be really
interesting to get to see this character
brought to life
i know i can't wait alright but now
let's move on to the breaking news
let me show you which actors hbo just
hired and what characters they will
portray
now before i attempt to read any further
i just want to let everyone know
i do not know how to say some of these
names in fact
i've never seen some of these names
before until now so bear with me here
and cut me some slack
the british actor steve toussaint or to
saint
will be our lord corliss valeron aka the
sea snake
the lord of house valeron a valyrian
bloodline azoda's house targaryen
the sea snake is the most famed nautical
adventurer in the history
of westeros he built his house into a
powerful seat that is even richer than
the lannisters
and that claims the largest navy in the
world so it almost sounds like the
lannisters and the greyjoys combined
not only does he have fat stacks but he
also has a massive fleet of ships behind
him
actress eve best will be our princess
rhaenys valeron
now this character rhaenys is a dragon
rider and she's also
wife to the character i named before
lord caloris valeron
she was known as the queen who never was
who was passed over as the heir to the
iron throne
at the great council because the realm
favored her cousin viserys
simply for being a male her and her
husband will be fighting for rhaenyra
targaryen
now i have no idea how to say the next
name but the actor
rice iphones will be serato hightower
the father of allison hightower
as well as the hand of the king who
loyally and faithfully serves both his
king
and the realm as the hand sees it the
greatest threat to the realm
is the king's brother daemon and his
position as the heir to the throne
as you can see these characters really
do not like each other
and last but certainly not least we have
actress sonoya mizuno asmasaria
she came to westeros with nothing sold
more times than she can recall
and she could have wilted but instead
she rose to become the most trusted
and most unlikely ally of prince daemon
targaryen the heir to the throne
again if you want to know more about all
of these characters and what roles they
will have during the dance of dragons
i would suggest watching my other video
that is linked down below
like i said before in that video i
explain all the different things we
should see
in house of the dragon well it's
becoming even more official my friends
we are one step closer to having
westeros back on our television screens
hbo has hired four more key characters
to help fill out the respective sides of
the blacks and the greens
not only have they hired a handful of
the main characters but now they're
starting to bring in some of their
strongest supporters
since we may only be about 8 weeks away
from filming i have a feeling there will
be more announcements very soon
there are still a lot more characters
they have to add to the series and my
guess is
they're already in talks with other
actors and actresses who may fit these
roles if you want to stay up to date
with any and all information regarding
house of the dragon you should consider
subscribing to my channel now
i will be making lots of videos for the
foreseeable future
hopefully i will see all of you back
here for the next one i will see you
again
soon bye
[Music]
so
you